doncic got into the lane no place to go
good defense on him
back on the drive pj got in front of him
made the shot anyway
gotcha outside pj tucker guarding
hardaway
on the perimeter now tate
guards dodge and he hits a three what a
tough shot
he is a big wide body see how he creates
a contact to go through
back to the middle again wood picks him
up on the switch
[Applause]
notches will shoot it deep got it
and the ball's not moving very much just
staying between two guys and then
wood doesn't get back cauley stein has
beat wood down the court about three or
four times
[Applause]
conscience right by pj tucker and a
beautiful pass to willie cauley stein
of 19 from behind the three-point line
worst
night of the season and the rockets
can't stop lost the basketball but he
lost it to one of his teammates and gets
it right back four seconds down to three
down to two dodges puts it up and in
what a player gotcha is now with 31
points
15 rebounds and nine assists
second game this season with 30 or more
and another basket by the mavericks
dallas jumped on houston early
and never got headed they were able to
keep that lead all the way as dachick
puts the icing
on the cake